so tell me where the idea for
interceptor came from well interceptor
began
it was an idea i wanted to write because
i wanted to move from novels into
directing movies but i had to come up
with something that would be
thrilling and fast but also you know
make makeable at a certain budget so i
was going to write this story set in
like an alaskan cia listening post
and this this cia agent was going to
hear you know
missiles being fired and had a direct
line to the white house
and as i prepared that i discovered
sbx1 and fought greeley and the
interceptor missile program
so
and i found that that was far more
interesting and so once i set the story
on spx-1 i had my gripping action
thriller
especially when you discover that it
really does take
24 minutes for a nuclear missile to fly
from russia to the us and you have 12
minutes to stop it as an action thriller
writer i i had my story then the timing
of it it's remarkably well timed did you
was that just luck of the draw was it
held or anything like that
uh no no it was purely coincidental i
wrote interceptor in 2017
uh and it went through the vicissitudes
of hollywood uh and no we it got the
it got the green light
in late 2020 we filmed it in 21 so yeah
um
purely coincidental that it's it's
becoming rather frighteningly applicable
now you said you filmed in 2021 did you
have a lot of trouble with the covid
process
we filmed in in sydney australia and we
that was where we were just
totally lucky we filmed in that middle
period where sydney was was open
uh and very very safe
we did have covered protocols on the set
um but no we got very lucky we filmed i
was about three quarters of the way
through the edit when sydney went into
lockdown again
so
we
we were just fortunate that is that is
blind luck
um what is the difference in your
process between writing a novel and
writing a screenplay a novel is like
running a marathon a screenplay is like
usain bolt running the 100 meter sprint
at the olympics
there is there is no extraneous stuff in
a script and the idea for interceptors
suited a script because it would not
have had enough
depth of story to fill a 400 page book
but for a screenplay
it just rocketed along
and it was funny with interceptor that
we had a few offers
for people to buy the script uh but they
didn't want me to direct it and so so we
walked so the process is different um
and they're different arts you know
writing a novel is a
a far more
a long play long form
uh prospect whereas a screenplay is
short sharp fast get in get out make it
as exciting as possible did the
experience of directing live up to your
expectations
yes it was great
it's funny you know when you write a
novel
it's a it's a joy but it's a solitary
joy uh creating a story and when you
make a movie you get to work with all
these creative people and you get to
share
that creative joy
and that's that was just
wonderful so i i thoroughly enjoyed it i
was very very prepared i've been waiting
for about you know 36 years to do this
since i saw the making of return of the
jedi on tv so
i was ready to go
were there was there anything that you
found to be um
more or less difficult than what you
expected you know generally no uh if if
you're ready um
i mean you you have to be prepared to be
a director and you have to have all the
answers and i think
because i wrote the script
i had pictured the whole story in my
mind so anybody had a question what was
elsa's costume supposed to look like
what did the command center look like i
had all the answers can you talk a
little bit about the process of
writing for such a tiny set and did it
make things more difficult
or or easier because you were very
limited you know
keeping a story in a confined space is a
writing challenge
and
we used every square inch of that set
from the outer tunnels for the gunfight
for the unit tunnel for the first fight
that elsa has with a giant six foot two
guy
you have to keep it interesting and the
good thing about that command center is
it's just intrinsically interesting
it's got this map screen in the middle
it's got live
security camera footage those security
cameras were live while we were filming
it's got a direct line to the white
house it's got you know the submarine
being tracked it's got the televisions
so as long as you keep people interested
you can get away with having your story
in this single location as long as that
location is interesting if anything it
becomes a part of the story how much of
it was
based on fact versus how much of it was
stuff that you kind of guessed at or
made up the joy of setting your story in
highly classified places is that nobody
can prove you wrong
that's great
i mean who's gonna say oh no that's what
that's no no no that's what that's not
what sbx1 looks like there'd be
breaching classified information so
when you go into the classified stuff
the world is your oyster it's like the
hunt for in october it's fantastic
that said
the flight time for missiles is true 24
minutes and 12 minutes to shoot them
down uh spx-1 does exist fort greeley
exists on a on a more serious note
the sexual harassment subplot of the
lead jj
is based on
true
incidents that i looked up things like
bounty hunts on women who have you know
brought complaints in the military that
does happen
this has been something i've done in my
career as a novelist you
you tell a fun fast-paced entertaining
story
but you grounded in a solid reality and
that seems to work rather well it's
worked for me so far
can you talk a little bit about chris
hemsworth's cameo how did that um
get involved or how did
he come on to the screen uh chris picked
it chris chris had read the script uh
a long while ago with elsa and um and
obviously the producers of the movie are
saying hey you know chris be great if
you were you know in the movie
not judgement
and chris himself came back
and he said you know
i could play that dude in the uh the tv
store
and
and it was it was fantastic uh we
i he'd asked what the look was and i
said well this is the kind of look i'm
going for and um
with chris
uh chris is a really just genuine nice
guy
but once you get on the set
he is laser focused you don't mess
around
and so once he was on the set he was
like okay matt what do you want me to do
where do you want me to go what are we
doing here and i had that
that night we filmed we took over
a tv store in sydney it was like a best
buy in sydney
and we took it over
and i had every single moment for chris
laid out we left a lot of that on the
cutting room floor i have a whole lot
more
footage of chris hemsworth in
he's he's dynamite he's just he's he's
that good um and and we have we have
some photos of elsa she came to the set
that day and you see the two of them
together and they're just lovely
they're a really nice couple
well they're telling me to wrap up so um
thank you so much i really appreciate
you taking the time today you're very
welcome thank you very much
you